hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today is my birthday and it's also the
day we hit 500,000 subscribers so
instead of a typical video I just
thought we play some games and just have
fun for funs sake so if you press
subscribe I really do appreciate it and
this is your aquatic watching a terrible
player fight for a jet come on anybody
else want my chest
this is mattress there are many blankets
mine is the best come on where are you I
have a semi on and now I'm trash again
okay okay come out oh there you are
there's somebody else I was fighting
sorry sir I got this this is my game my
first game of the day no I'm not I am
the king of pickaxe battles who wants to
take me on oh come on it's Harry Lee
yeah Howard Stern I do not lose pickaxe
battles try me but it was at this moment
the atom knew you play that dude there
is literally a weapon just in here go
and take it
tell me nice in there is a weapon go on
take the damn weapon man
don't hide this I will get your weapon
with here is this why can you not help a
brother out sometimes this is why we
can't have nice things bury us
let's go in the Fox let's go in the fort
let's fight inside come on come join me
anyone know yeah
my keys are outside let's have a truce
while we pick up some bullets okay oh
I've got fifty now like I really have a
friend
Oh real friend oh that lovely truce is
over it was nice having a friend for a
few seconds what do you think go
where are you licking we ripped in
when we drop in boys where we drop in
loud tilt in Star Wars you can't lose me
I am the ultimate default where's your
friend in Allah be with you that's where
she is
I'm the greatest in the world except for
a minor incline it's my worst enemies
just a random incline just leave me
alone when I find one bullet mate it's
all over it's lights out one bullet
here's the one bullet this opportunity
comes once in a lifetime yo did I just
quote Eminem I need to snap back to
reality they know gravity we should with
order I didn't think hold up hold up
okay so I'm editing this now and I've
just noticed that that line could be
edited together with other lines in this
video to make this hospitality mom's
sphaghetti you don't know the amount of
hours I wasted making that little bit
anyway back to the video
okay come on you which is okay where's
your friend
come on little Mike strewth my unlucky
we've got to let him win protect him at
all costs stay away from my little guy
it's another Raven it's another every
single time I die it's all Raven we are
going Raven hunting where those Ravens
your Raven you can live we're looking
for Ravens Raven come on these two of
you where's the other one you spin me
all right baby right round quoth the
raven nevermore
can you see me surprise me try yeah it's
okay what's alive I can't I can't figure
out the vertical audio I never know when
someone's below me or above me like now
where the hell is that is out the window
wait the heck is that sad oh well let's
get involved
here we come Joe quick what is your
friend John wick in the nick we need to
make a t-shirt on that where nothing man
reviews when you need a break right in
the balls surely that was not the master
plan
who'da thought you did someone in the
ball sack would make me so happy
nope nope nope I renounce all sane or
religion I've just kill me I'm done
finish do it do it
bulimia it's really not nice dead dead
dead dead dead I feel like Ethan hunts
illegitimate brother Mike
[Music]
that's my loot hot streak three in a row
[Applause]
like I've never hit three scopes nights
in a row ever trash we did behind there
I don't know what you are that's four
bullets in a row can I have five we will
claim this farm as our own but my name
is Hunt Mike see you behind the chimney
come over right one bullet we have one
bullet that we don't take it until the
very last second come on come on over
free shots turn this time to faces
all right for me that was seven bullets
six kills but it's like looking my best
ever ever ever always the new silenced
one let's test out this baby what what
that was
whoa I'm not gonna shoot what we're
going back we are going back I promise
that was on target and the bloom to get
about six feet to the right mom
spaghetti
two men midday Casabella three left have
no bullets I will be back I can't
remember where bullets
please be some in here yeah boy I mean
yes I found some bullets
I feel invigaron lets us run back
let us galavant lets us re-engage with
the enemy and hopefully Surprise them
like this surprise mother this is my
lazy Lynx thank you all for coming
stop jumping around this isn't duck hunt
what is now I want to be like those pros
who do all these trick shots
the problem is I can't hit Tammy if I
were to hit that then oh oh oh for me
that's like really really really good I
know that's really mediocre ly average
for everybody else but for me that's
really impressive
where's your friend oh he is fun all oh
my word you had the semi-auto I hate
this gun with a passion the bloom is
ridiculous let me tell you a story about
the semi-auto so seconds go pin but
watch watch no no no no I am NOT giving
up I am gonna win this with bloom on my
side card blows come on blow
penis shops I've mastered the penis shot
on this game who riffs Oh his partner in
crimes got to see him its brain and men
anybody goes over there diagonally right
one you try to warn you have a nice day
[Music]
let me begin I came to win battle me
good how many can you have I've never
seen someone with somebody funky funky
lunge one oh I was gonna say if you land
one I will give you a free hit it's all
yours I will not shoot until you shoot
sir oh my word for a legit second there
I look like I knew how to fortnight I
don't I'm terrible
but I love this game
[Music]